all right let's try this little
experiment yeah don't worry that's not
gonna be the intro okay so cognitive
just is there seriously another
helicopter it's a plane this time what
do you want me to do
wait the shelf is right next to me today
we're talking about cognitive dissonance
what it is why it's important and how
you can overcome it how to deal with it
in a more healthy way and in doing so
make yourself a better version of
yourself cognitive dissonance is when
you have one or more thoughts in your
mind that conflict each other say you're
a smoker you're probably thinking I
smoke cigarettes and you're also
probably thinking cigarettes are bad for
me people do this all the time they have
an activity that they do on a regular
basis they know they do it on a regular
basis and they also know it's not very
good for them most smokers have these
two thoughts in their mind they both
conflict each other but they smoke
anyways this causes cognitive dissonance
cognitive dissonance is extremely
uncomfortable they've done studies that
have shown that people who have a lot of
cognitive dissonance going on or in
other words they have a lot of
conflicting beliefs going on they
actually hold tension in their bodies
and are physically uncomfortable not
just mentally uncomfortable they've also
showed that people who exist in a state
of cognitive dissonance will do whatever
it takes to get out of that dissonance
and there are four different things that
people do to get out of that dissonance
number one is to change their thoughts
they think to themselves damn I'm a
smoker I smoke and also damn I'm a
smoker and smokings bad for me so what
they do is they change one of those
thoughts in order to achieve cognitive
harmony an example of changing your
thought in order to achieve harmony
would be saying smoking isn't really bad
for me or an even more extreme case
would be I don't really smoke both are
very unhealthy ways to deal with
cognitive dissonance the next thing that
people do is they change their behavior
and in my opinion this is the most
healthy way to do
with cognitive dissonance if you
actually believe that is truly and
objectively bad for you to smoke then
you should change your behavior and
according to that and stop smoking
another thing that people do to
facilitate their cognitive dissonance is
they add a thought so
they say yeah I smoke cigarettes yes
it's bad for me but also other people
smoke cigarettes too and they're not
dying yet so it's totally fine and the
fourth thing that people do is
trivialization so they say to themselves
yeah I smoke cigarettes yeah it's bad
for me but I just don't really care
needless to say number two changing your
behavior in accordance to what you
really believe is the only way to deal
with cognitive dissonance so I would say
find the things in your life that are
causing cognitive dissonance things that
you're doing that you know are bad for
you and change your behaviors in
alignment with what you truly believe
and mentally and physically you'll feel
better you'll be more confident and
you'll be more true to yourself that's
all today thank you for watching if you
like this video hit that like button if
you like videos like these in general
hit that subscribe button I have a
Facebook page down below that you should
join because there are a whole bunch of
people like you who like
self-improvement there you can post your
own self-improvement advice if you have
Facebook it's a no brainer link is in
the description join the inner circle
have a nice day
at first we gotta create a fox here's
the snout here's the tail here's our
beautiful all-in-all very strong back
legs sturdy